foreign
Michigan what's up Jason
hey John thanks for having me you got it
brother what's up man
um so first of all uh I I sorry if I
Stumble over my words I'm very nervous
oh dude hey I Stumble and I'm not even
nervous I Stumble all the time you're
good man you're in good company so
what's up so this is this is a little
long-winded uh I was hoping that you
could help uh me and my wife uh
do something
um let's do it and when I when I tell
you this uh I just want you to know that
uh me and my wife are very much people
Pleasers and we don't like
confrontations so um you called the
right guy yeah awesome uh I have a
family member that I was on the phone
with early early this morning
trying to encourage a significant
confrontation that they need to have in
their life and so I love a good
confrontation so let's do it awesome uh
so we have we have come across a
financial issue that may drive us out of
state
um we told my in-laws the other day and
as soon as they got back to their house
uh without us knowing they started to
put together a financial plan for us
what happened what happened
uh so um we uh unfortunately the day
okay costs and uh tuition debt and all
that stuff it's too much for us right
now so we have to like we're planning on
just kind of like selling a home and
kind of using those proceeds this set
off some debt maybe staying with my
parents down in uh in North Carolina for
a little bit to kind of reset
um that's that's kind of what was going
on
so you have a lot of debt and you own a
home you're thinking about selling the
home paying off everything and just kind
of getting control delete from zero
exactly yeah so we don't owe anyone
anything and why North Carolina is there
you have jobs there uh my family uh
lives there we do not have jobs there
yet but I'm looking
okay and so you told
basically you told your in-laws hey we
we don't have we've got more bills than
we do income the job prospects here
we're not gonna be able to earn our way
out in this community plus the cost plus
whatever
have a nice career job right now
um but again I I with the amount of
money we oh I can't make enough soon
enough
um can I can I tell you that it also
sounds like you want to get out of this
part of the country
you're a genius uh I do actually
um so I was already playing that in the
future but listen listen
well before we even get to the Crux of
your question when you have these kind
of conversations with in-laws and with
with other people be 100 honest
okay
like I want to move away from this town
too
okay you see what I'm saying sure and
that way people don't swoop in and try
to solve all of your problems because
they don't know all your problems they
just know the one that you put on the
table which is well we're really
struggling with our air conditioner so
we're gonna sell the house and it's like
suddenly there's repairman at your house
that you didn't even hire and it's like
well also I hate the house and our
marriage is crumble it right there's all
these other things going on
um okay so you want to get home and be
around your family is your wife in on
that
uh she's followed it and we had a
discussion in the past about it and we
kind of we kind of uh got to the point
where it's like hey like if we're gonna
make that move that we got to make sure
that uh it's for good reason and that
we're kind of set up uh appropriately
like having jobs and all that stuff do
not move without a job okay exactly yeah
and that's what that's what we're
planning on doing not moving without a
job okay all right so um you tell her
in-laws and they start making Financial
plans for you what does that mean
uh so uh so they they came up with this
this plan uh let's say their plan was
essentially like a chart of our pros and
cons and also they created like a
color-coded chart of like our mental
health and our happiness no no
absolutely not no they get no vote on
that zero run run go to go today I just
told you to don't go without a job go
right now
yeah that's that's yeah exactly what I'm
getting to and So the plan is
essentially uh their plan would work
financially but it requires like signing
legal to contract no I person I
personally was not okay with that my
wife yeah that's what I thought no no no
no no no
don't be insane no I I don't like it
sounds crazy I don't enter into legal
contracts with loved ones
yeah I shake hands
or I give the money away or I say no
yes that was my my gut instinct and I
guess that comes to my uh and also like
currently uh and to give them peace of
mind we're also sharing like in-depth
finances no no no no no no they don't
your job isn't to give them peace of
mind that's not your job that's their
job they're grown-ups they're the
parents their job is to go figure out
their own peace of mind not to use y'all
to try to get it yeah I'm trying to like
you know make a decision for my for my
family and it's like it's hard for it's
hard to consider them into that I'm
trying to block that out yes they don't
get a vote
yeah so a couple of my questions here uh
Are We Wrong to believe that uh that
they have too much involvement in our
lives and finances is it best if we tell
them that we love them but we don't need
their approval to make decisions and
asking and asking for all this
information kind of makes us feel like
we can't be trusted or we that we can't
support ourselves
um so hold on hold on that's what you
told them
um I that's what we're trying to figure
out how to you told them that
you told them that we have to get rid of
our home because we can't make enough
money to survive in this part of the
country and they probably said ah we're
calling bull crap on that we see how you
spend your money we see how y'all live
and when you told them that and you also
didn't say and we just want to move we
want a new adventure we're going to move
down south where it's cheaper where we
can keep more of our paycheck we're
going to do X and Y and Z like fill in
the blank why who cares why I want to go
fishing every weekend and you can't do
that up here I'm tired of the cold
whatever reasons you only get by my
family whatever you want to do but you
didn't tell them that you invited them
into a conversation where you said we're
struggling so much we have to get rid of
our house
and you have to understand for our
parents generation getting rid of your
house was everything
and so you told them essentially we're
about to be destitute and we're going to
move in with somebody else's parents
and they swooped in to say whoa whoa
whoa whoa
right so you invited them in kind of
like a vampire you opened the door and
you said come on in and then they
started biting everybody and you're mad
that they're biting y'all invited them
in yeah and you didn't tell them the
whole story when they came in
yeah because in the past they said hey
you can't don't make don't make
decisions based on emotion just make it
also like just the straight numbers
and um and so we're trying to we're just
kind of leading in with the numbers but
it's it's starting to feel like they're
kind of coming in with some emotions too
so yeah of course they are anyone who
says hey never use emotion that's
emotional I'm just kidding it's not but
but you know what I'm saying yes they
want here's what they want do you have
kids
yes they don't want to lose their
grandkids and so they will do everything
they can including coming up with
color-coded mental health charts to help
you stay
yeah that's right I figure and and to
put a kicker on it um my my
father-in-law just got diagnosed with
stage four cancer and he's going through
chemo so it's like there's a lot of
guilt
um involved in in this decision we don't
we're kind of about this weird
Crossroads and it's really hard yes
it's okay if someone right the second
isn't the time to go
that's okay
what I think you and your wife need to
do is to back out of this whole thing
hit pause on everything back all the way
out because she's also going to be
grieving and her dad has a terminal
cancer diagnosis
step out of the whole thing
get somebody to come over and watch your
kids for half a day and you all go to a
really nice restaurant in the morning
and y'all say okay what do we want our
life to look like for the next five
years
yeah
and if dad's got a prognosis that he's
gonna not be with us for in six months
then let's consider sitting around for
six months and helping out
yeah
I don't know that you need to go knock
on the door and have some Grand
conversation about
um
you all have too much influence in our
life and blah blah all that kind of
stuff
a simple well hey let's let's take a
look at your bank income statements and
you a simple uh no thank you I want to
keep those personal
it suffices
okay and when you say things like well
we're both just people Pleasers that's
passing the buck just say no
okay and yeah remember this line choose
guilt over resentment every time
okay okay you're gonna feel because
you're all about people Pleasers you're
gonna feel guilty anytime you put up a
boundary
also don't not tell the full truth
because it it's easier
okay
all right so when me and my wife moved
here I had a like a world-class
professional opportunity at a
world-class University it's my dream job
if I got fired today I would they I
would love to go back to my exact job
they were amazing okay and and my wife
and I were very clear we wanted a new
adventure
we'd both been born and raised in the
same stay we've been in the same city
for 15 years or plus it was time for us
to go try a new adventure
and we told everybody that that way
there wasn't this like well what about
the job and when I went in to say hey
I'm transitioning out and they're like
well you want to negotiate the state
like there wasn't this big drawn out
negotiation because it was only part of
the reason I wanted to go
yeah
and so I want you and your wife to be on
the same page because my gut tells me
the other half of this conversation is
is she is so used to listening to them
she likes the idea of not listening to
them but she's still going to do
whatever they say
yeah
is that part of it too yeah there's a
lot of uh well she's even more other
people please than I am and she kind of
shuts down when she gets into these
tough times conversations and we we both
kind of like uh just kind of not our nod
our heads and just kind of accept what's
what's happening and what people tell us
to do yeah
at some point you've got to
you'll have to grow up and be in adults
both of you
yeah and you can't continue to let your
mom mommies and daddies run your life
um you have to decide what's best for
our family what does our family want to
do
and do we have some responsibilities I I
think helping out with if if she is the
only child I think helping out with
stage four cancer dad is Noble I I would
I would delay moving if you don't have
to
um
also I'm not going to give Financial
records to my in-laws and I love my
in-laws but if my mother-in-law said hey
send me all of your tax return I'm not
going to say I'm not sitting in the Hat
I wouldn't give that to my parents it's
mine it's me and my wife that's ours and
my accountant and one buddy I have that
I trust with those hard conversations
because he gives me some some brutal
wisdom but other than that they're just
mine and so I I'm
or let's do this shift your people
pleasing
to you
and to your wife
start there if you're gonna please
people if you have to please somebody
seek seek and say what's best for us
right now what's going to bring us joy
and then
how can we love and take care of the
people around us because now we're able
to do that because we filled our picture
up so anyway thanks for the call man do
not enter into transactional Financial
relationships with your family that is
the sure way to burn the whole
relationship to the ground
they want to give you money with no
strings and you choose to take it great
that's fine
um if you want to move just because
you're tired of living where you live
and you want to go try a new place you
want to go back home with your family
great go for it but you and your wife
you and your wife need to be on the same
page talking the same language with the
same crystal clear picture of what
tomorrow's going to look like
which ought to take a half day go spend
the day together and dream big weep
together grieve together and walk away
with a plan here's what the next one two
three years is going to look like and
then hang on brother because it comes
fast